so whenever you had the thing with the
lakers with the kobe thing did were you
shocked at how some comics treated you
or behaved toward you or responded
yeah at first but i mean like you can't
really be upset when you try to troll
people and you do troll them you know
and you get them to be upset
uh i mean like terrestrial i had to ruin
it against the lakers but like
it's just sports you know i don't really
care but i've been [ __ ] on the
lakers for for 20 years since i started
killing shows in l.a during the playoffs
i'm like [ __ ] the lakers oh that's a
good point i started really reveling in
the [ __ ] hatred of them oh that would
be the worst too dude that happened to
me a couple times we're like oh yeah
we're not gonna do it tonight because
they made it to a game of five i'm like
it's it's game [ __ ] four and they're
up three nothing and it's a first round
like come on you [ __ ] fairweather
[ __ ] come out to the
comedy underground places like the
lakers i will say it seemed like they
just it's just too stacked i don't like
these stacks exactly they're [ __ ]
collusion for sure
[ __ ] them
this whole bought team now
that's and that's a fake championship
last year was an aau [ __ ]
championship nobody respects that as a
real championship two years ago yeah
yeah two years ago um
but yeah it's like you thought but then
when at first i was like god damn you
guys come on don't you know it's just a
comic making a joke like what are you
doing why would you take this stance but
then you're like
step back you're like no i got you i
mean you you gotta agree with me you're
trying to make it i wanted a [ __ ]
easy thing
yeah that was interesting i was thinking
about that last night like
does
like
it's weird when you walk the line
because you want to have you want to get
people upset but you don't want to get
them
so upset that they're like so like a
couple line crosses to me were like you
know like they call like not me but like
other people they call my manager at
home like we're come [ __ ] you up yeah
goddamn and we're always latinos dude
yeah or blacks or whatever but or just
dumb laker fan it's like no one from
london gave a [ __ ] about that you know
and they were like huh i mean if i'm
gonna fight in front of rooney or
something they'd be like don't do that
you know but it's just like yeah i
triggered you but i did enjoy that all
these comics are like if you don't like
a joke just leave the room it's not that
hard and then they got one that
triggered them and then they didn't know
how to just leave the room they had to
take the stance of some jokes go too far
for the first time in their lives they
were like some jokes go too far and i'm
like yeah i feel like i exposed them
into hypocrites it was great i really
enjoyed it that and that's what i was
thinking yesterday because i even
watched like a reaction that i had to
when it happened
and i was like
yeah i was trying to make and it's
different because i i feel almost
differently now you watch it back it
doesn't even have like the same the
notch right so people like too soon i'm
like well no if you wait too long
which is always the issue with timing of
jokes just like you're saying with
chappelle like with uh david tell you
and dave obviously is a big name for
good comedians i just realized that
chappelle in a tail oh yeah a regular
name like dave chappelle david tell dave
taylor the top three yeah
yeah
i'm david duke all set up
one of the great great leaders great
early troller
yeah i actually love jews and blacks i
just say [ __ ] it gets me votes for sure
i like wearing white what can i do
oh yeah i even look i even put this on
late september you know what i'm saying
after like yeah
um um but no i that that's one thing
looking back i was like this is all so
fascinating because it's like it made me
wonder well
what what choices am i making and
talking about because i'm scared of
repercussions what choices am i making
and talking about because do you get
involved with the mop because like the
mob is like well let me go with them i
might not agree but let me just walk the
line and there's a safety in that too
there's a safety in that dude i remember
they had a news thing that came out like
a few years back about me it was just
about it wasn't anything real bad but it
was just it wasn't anything bad really
it was just something about my life and
it was but it was on i remember being at
the gym and seeing on the ticker on the
bottom of like
it was a slow news day yeah and they had
my name on that's cool and i was like oh
my god everybody and but it was so scary
to me well they said you're a fake
mullet they sang it on yeah yeah you've
been clipping on your mullet for years
sewing it in
sean comes over with betsy ross and sews
it into the back of my head he's like we
gotta get it ready i'm like
like you can't mention this by the way
sorry
dude i was in thailand at this [ __ ]
hippie place once and some ladies sold
tie on dreads for white
people their life for the week that they
were there
but here's the crazy part so whoever
buys those and puts them on they get in
trouble for cultural appropriation but
the business of it just keeps totally
fine
oh yeah who do you think some of those
black lives matter shirts it's just some
white dude he's like i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm making this in indonesia and i'm
[ __ ] cashing in
but yeah so how did you feel when you
saw your name in the ticker or what
happened it made i felt overwhelmed i
remember calling the publicist this guy
rob greenwald great guy
is it yeah rob's a great guy man great
guy well rob i remember dude i just now
remember i saw him out he went to see
your jew taping of the or jew uh you
were running at the comedy store and i
saw him right after and he's like i'm
jewish man and uh and i love you know he
was just saying how much he loved your
especially i just remembered that um
but anyway uh so yeah i just remember
just texting him or emailing him
dude i just make it stop i don't want
here's what it was it was too much
stuff that was out of my control
happening at once yeah that i had no
control over like little articles and um
it was about dating i dated like a real
housewives lady right and so
it was just a slow news day so for some
reason it was just
but i remember being in the gym and
seeing it go on the ticker and i'm like
what isn't there a stock or something
that's how you found out about it that's
supposed to be on there yeah wow and
then i remem and then it was all over
and i remember texting my manager um
etai rice and this guy and rob grieve
and just being like guys can you make it
stop and it wasn't
it wasn't bad
but it was just something that was so
out of my control
and i feel like for me as a comedian you
always want to be able to control your
little world and that's what's so
scary about
the media and the way things are
nowadays is that there's there's these
other
tidal waves sometimes that you have to
be willing to [ __ ] ride yeah yeah you
have to like sit back on like if you
want to poke a bear you can't be that
mad when the bear swings back you know
because that's like that and i'm too
afraid i think you're like a kelly
slater i feel like you're willing to be
out there on the way like i didn't like
all the negative stuff but like the act
on itself that troll was maybe my best
one i mean i brought a city to its knees
you know i mean
so like it would have been nice it was
two weeks after my special taping
instead of two weeks before oh yeah but
like i crushed that town dude i [ __ ]
crushed that town and i crushed all of
la comedy i expose them for the [ __ ]
garbage hypocrites with no integrity
that they are
yeah with just a little a pin prick of
negativity on my own account and you
just watch them spread it oh
it was the best one it was the best one
would you do it again you think or did
you have any percent yeah i mean there's
no way i can't because here's the deal
man i i've committed to to this life and
and and by this life i don't mean
offensive i mean doing the jokes that i
find funny whenever i find them funny
and that's one that's one thing i really
admire about you the most man thanks
buddy so so if you start considering the
repercussions
and not like moral repercussions like
like i yeah i'm not gonna go to
somebody's funeral and do that that's
the wrong place right but i'm like no
i'm doing it to my audience i can't be
worried about if it's going to take a
thing i have a nice life
and i'm completely free yeah so i'm not
going to give that up because i might
have more money or be able to do more
things
and like by the way i took a lie
detector on this on legion of skanks
they're like like do you regret the kobe
tweet
oh i have to go back
absolutely crushed
the reaction maybe but it would have
been nice if people were like hey guys
that's what a joke is you have to allow
comics to make jokes
right right right and that's really i
think that's the thing that
we should all be saying we should all be
learning each other because we want to
tell young comics we will get your back
if the line moves behind you we're not
talking about action we're talking about
whatever you're trying to do for a joke
we will have your back young comics yeah
we will always say like and and not to
say like hey i didn't find it funny but
you this is right not leave that [ __ ]
out
just be like yeah guys clearly here's
the joke here's what he's going for
right well did you find a phone he's
like what's the difference it's got
nothing to do with it there's plenty of
like specials from comics or that aren't
funny that i would never mention because
it's not offensive right so you're not
like
this guy's special wasn't good like you
wouldn't say that so why would you say
it when they're under attack yeah it's
nutty i have had a few people apologize
to me a couple like black comics
specifically was like hey
no
he's a he's an actor he's fine no no he
did he's like i told you i had to say
something he was not like actually right
that is actually a pretty good person
me and samuel was saying that he came up
to me i thought it was going to beat me
up and they was like i told you i'm
going to say something all right buddy
and then sam's like oh you got to
respect the honesty
i guess so yeah that's true too i think
is yeah like if somebody didn't say yeah
everybody's playing kind of their game
or playing the best game that they can
yeah but mike yard came up to me was
like dude when i saw that i was like
what the [ __ ] are you doing and then
somebody's like oh i get it like you
make fun of like dead celebrities
because you're poking fun at like the
people who overvalue these lives of
celebrities like i get it now i didn't
get it at first i'm like oh thanks or or
or
kareem green was like uh not kareem
green jimmy martinez was like uh yeah i
said some [ __ ] about you man but i
shouldn't have uh i get it now i get
what you were doing i should have i
should have like defended you as a
comedian i'm like thanks for saying that
yeah so a few people did but
you know now that the emotions are gone
but it's also fun when you see people
still mad about one of the many like
lines i've crossed yeah i'm still angry
somebody's the other day was like
putting out a beyonce tweet that i made
like what about this yeah
exactly i'll never forgive you
okay
i'm definitely gonna think you're a dork
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you